Hey there, everybody. Ira Glass here. It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago. I'm just here for a minute to say we have a special show for you today. One of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, has been reporting a lot on education and schools.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。欢迎收听WBEZ芝加哥电台带来的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我占用大家一分钟时间，因为今天我们要播出特别节目。我们的制作人查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）一直在深度报道教育和学校相关话题。
And three years ago, she did this story that's about a part of education that everybody knows about, but I think we do not talk about much at all, not in a way that feels like anything. And this is one of my favorite shows we've ever done and full of surprise turns and twists. And I don't want to waste any more time here setting this up, so I'm just going to hand over the show to Chana so we can get to it. Here she is.
三年前，她做过一个关于教育的专题故事。这是每个人都知道，但我认为我们平时几乎从不谈论的一个方面，至少没有触及到实质。这是我最喜欢的节目之一，充满了意想不到的转折和波澜。我不想再浪费时间做铺垫了，直接把节目交给查娜，让我们进入正题。有请查娜。
In 2005, Lisa and Angela were part of a program that brought their two schools together, sort of a classroom exchange. Kids from Lisa's school would see Angela's school and vice versa. They thought their students would get a lot out of meeting each other and learning about one another's schools because their students spend their school days in two very different places.
2005年，丽莎（Lisa）和安吉拉（Angela）参与了一个将她们两所学校联系在一起的项目，算是一种课堂交流活动。丽莎学校的学生会去参观安吉拉的学校，反之亦然。她们认为，学生们通过见面交流和了解对方的学校，会大有裨益，因为学生们在截然不同的两个地方度过学校时光。
Lisa Greenbaum's school, University Heights High School, is a public school. It's 97% black and Hispanic. It's located in the poorest congressional district in the country, the South Bronx.
丽莎·格林鲍姆（Lisa Greenbaum）的学校，大学高地高中（University Heights High School），是一所公立学校。这里97%的学生是黑人和拉丁裔。它位于全国最贫困的国会选区——南布朗克斯区。
Angela Vassos' school, Fieldston, is also in the Bronx. But it's one of New York City's elite private schools. It's 70% white. It's known as a progressive school. One in five kids gets financial aid, which is helpful because last year tuition was $43,000.
安吉拉·瓦索斯（Angela Vassos）的学校，菲尔德斯顿学校（Fieldston），也在布朗克斯，但它是纽约市的精英私立学校之一。那里70%的学生是白人，以进步教育闻名。五分之一的学生获得经济援助，这很有必要，因为去年的学费是43,000美元。
These two schools were three miles from each other, but the students basically needed a foreign exchange program to meet each other. The teachers started by having their students write letters to each other. They were pen pals for a while, which was going well.
这两所学校相距仅三英里，但学生们基本上需要一个交换生项目才能相见。老师们先让他们互通书信。他们做了一段时间笔友，进展还算顺利。
And then Lisa and Angela planned a time to get them together. Lisa, the public school teacher, says the moment her kids got off the bus at Fieldston, the private school, they had a dramatic reaction to what they saw.
后来，丽莎和安吉拉计划了一次面对面的交流。公立学校的老师丽莎说，当她的学生下校车到达菲尔德斯顿私立学校的那一刻，他们对所见之景产生了剧烈的反应。
They couldn't believe the campus. They felt like everyone was looking at them. And one of the students started screaming and crying. Like, this is unfair. This is-- I don't want to be here. I'm leaving. I'm leaving right now. I'm going home. We were like, Melanie, it's OK. You should stay with the group. Let's talk, you know?
他们无法相信那个校园。他们觉得每个人都在盯着他们看。其中一名学生开始尖叫哭泣，说：“这不公平，我不想待在这里，我要走，我现在就要回家。”我们当时就在说：“梅兰妮（Melanie），没事的，你应该和大家待在一起，让我们聊聊，好吗？”
Some context, University Heights, the public school these kids were coming from, it's small and friendly. There are no metal detectors. But it's a public school in a poor neighborhood. The kids share a building and a gym with another school.
补充一点背景：这些孩子所在的大学高地公立学校规模小而友好，没有金属探测器，但这毕竟是一所位于贫困街区的公立学校，学生们还和另一所学校共用教学楼和体育馆。
The private school, Fieldston, has an 18-acre campus on a hill. Stone buildings are connected by landscaped paths. Every few windows is the size of a garage door. There's a dance studio, an art gallery, a pool.
而菲尔德斯顿私立学校拥有一个位于山坡上的18英亩校园，石头建筑由景观小径连接，窗户大得像车库门，还有舞蹈室、艺术画廊和游泳池。
So on that first day, the public school kids, almost all of them Puerto Rican and Dominican kids from the South Bronx, walk onto the campus, look around at the quad, the trees, see the school's mission etched into the stone arches. Angela, the private school teacher from Fieldston, came to greet them and immediately noticed that one of the girls seemed upset.
于是第一天，几乎全部由南布朗克斯区的波多黎各和多米尼加裔孩子组成的公立学校学生，走进校园，看着方院、树木，看着刻在石拱门上的校训。菲尔德斯顿的私立学校老师安吉拉过来迎接他们，立刻注意到其中一个女孩似乎很难过。
And I went over to talk to her, as did Lisa. And she jumped up and she said, we've got to get out of here. We've got to get out of here. We've got to get out of here. And I thought it was a joke at the beginning. I didn't realize, you know?
我和丽莎一起走过去跟她说话。她跳起来说：“我们得离开这里，我们必须得离开这儿。”我起初以为她在开玩笑，我没意识到（情况的严重性）。
And it really was-- I mean, she went white, like completely white, you know? Blood drained from her face. And her friend was holding her and saying, calm down, Melanie. Calm down, Melanie. So it was just an awful situation. None of us had anticipated such a strong reaction.
但这确实是……我的意思是，她脸色煞白，完全变得苍白，你知道吗？血色从她脸上褪去。她的朋友抱住她说：“冷静点，梅兰妮，冷静点。”那真是一个可怕的情况。我们谁也没想到会有这么强烈的反应。
There are hundreds of programs right now that are trying to do some version of this exchange program to help people connect across a growing divide. For a lot of students, American public schools are more segregated than they were a generation ago, not less. The gap between rich and poor is wider than it's been since the Great Depression.
现在有成百上千个项目试图进行这种交换项目，帮助人们跨越日益扩大的鸿沟。对许多学生来说，美国的公立学校比一代人之前更加隔离，而不是相反。贫富差距也是自大萧条以来最严重的。
Basically, whatever gap you hear about-- income gap, achievement gap, racial divide-- these two groups of kids from University Heights and Fieldston exist on opposite sides. And just seeing across that divide, something so many of us never do, can be incredibly powerful.
基本上，你听说的任何差距——收入差距、学业成就差距、种族鸿沟——这两组来自大学高地和菲尔德斯顿的孩子正处于鸿沟的两端。仅仅是隔着鸿沟相望，这种我们大多数人从未做过的事情，可能就具有难以置信的冲击力。
In this case, from the very first few minutes, it was definitely dramatic. This incident when the kids visited Fieldston happened 10 years ago. And I heard this story from so many different people-- the teachers, kids from both schools. Allison Roland was a junior at the private school, Fieldston, at the time. She remembers the girl who freaked out.
在这种情况下，从最初的几分钟开始，过程确实充满戏剧性。孩子们参观菲尔德斯顿的这件事发生在10年前。我从很多人——老师、两所学校的孩子——那里听说了这个故事。艾莉森·罗兰（Allison Roland）当时是菲尔德斯顿私立学校的高二学生。她记得那个崩溃的女孩。
People were like, what happened? That was weird. But nobody really-- it was very behind the scenes.
大家都在问：“发生了什么？太奇怪了。”但没人真的——事情发生在幕后，大家没怎么在意。
Even more, she remembers the feeling she had seeing the girl freak out, feeling helpless.
更重要的是，她记得自己看着那个女孩崩溃时感到的那种无助感。
It's uncomfortable when you can't help someone not be uncomfortable. No one wants to feel like they're on the hill school on the top of the hill, and there are people-- it's uncomfortable. But at the same time, I totally understood where she was coming from in terms of it is messed up. It's crazy. Our educations have been so drastically different, and that's completely unfair.
当你无法帮助别人摆脱不适时，这种感觉很糟糕。没人想感觉自己站在山上的学校里，而另一些人……这很令人难受。但同时，我完全理解她为什么会那样，因为那确实很糟糕。这太疯狂了。我们受的教育截然不同，这完全不公平。
But what do you do in the moment when you're still a high school student, and you don't have the power-- like I don't have a degree. I couldn't become a politician in that moment and change-- I don't know. Making change just takes a long time.
但当你还是个高中生，没有权力的时候，你能做什么？我那时连学位都没有，在那一刻我也无法成为政治家去改变什么……我不知道，做出改变需要很长时间。
A lot of Fieldston students do go on to be politicians, and run Walt Disney and the New York Times, and host evening news programs, and design major American cities. And part of the point of programs like these that try to bridge the divide is-- seeing as the private school kids will likely go on to be important, influential people, maybe write education policy or finance new businesses-- it's good for them to know not everybody's life looks like theirs. But of course, then there's the question, what do the public school kids get out of it?
很多菲尔德斯顿的学生后来确实成为了政治家，经营华特迪士尼或《纽约时报》，主持晚间新闻节目，设计美国主要城市。而这类试图弥合鸿沟的项目目的之一是——鉴于私立学校的孩子未来很可能成为重要且有影响力的人，或许会制定教育政策或资助新商业——让他们知道并非每个人的生活都和他们一样，这很有益。但当然，随后就产生了一个问题：公立学校的孩子能从中得到什么？
Right now, there's a popular idea in education-- it pops up all over the place-- about exposure, that exposure is particularly important for poor kids-- not just important, that it can change destinies. You know, you take a group of kids to tour a college campus, they'll be more likely to go to college. Or if you just know someone who went to college, that'll help.
现在，教育界有一个流行的想法——到处都在出现——关于“接触”，认为接触对贫困孩子尤为重要，不仅是重要，甚至能改变命运。你知道，带一群孩子参观大学校园，他们上大学的可能性就会增加；或者如果你认识一个上过大学的人，那也会有帮助。
The idea is if you want a kid to move from one social class to another, that kid has to see what it looks like over there on the other side. Exposure is a tool for social change and economic mobility. Or it just sucks.
其逻辑是，如果你想让一个孩子从一个社会阶层跨越到另一个阶层，这个孩子必须亲眼看到另一边是什么样。接触是社会变革和经济流动的工具。或者，那也可能很糟。
You see how much you did not get, and it's shocking or painful. And you freak out, like that one girl, Melanie. The people who run programs like these hope that even if it's upsetting in the moment, ultimately, this kind of experience helps more than it hurts.
你看到了你缺少了多少，这很令人震惊或痛苦。然后你就会崩溃，像那个女孩梅兰妮一样。那些负责这些项目的人希望，即使当时让人难受，但最终这种经历的帮助大于伤害。
But nobody really knows because this is the kind of thing that plays out over time. It occurred to me that the group of kids who were part of that first year exchange between Fieldston and University Heights could answer this question. Does it hurt or help the public school kids?
但没人知道，因为这类事情是随着时间推移才显现的。我想到，那第一年参加菲尔德斯顿和大学高地交换项目的孩子们或许能回答这个问题：这到底是伤害了还是帮助了公立学校的孩子？
It's been 10 years. They're in their mid-20s now, so they've gone to college, gotten apartments and jobs. And it turns out this one experience really has shaped some of the public school kids in profound ways, ways I did not see coming. Today's show, what happens when you see the other side, and it looks a lot better?
十年过去了。他们现在二十多岁了，上了大学，有了公寓和工作。事实证明，这次经历确实以深刻的方式影响了一些公立学校的孩子，这种方式是我没预料到的。今天的节目将探讨：当你看到另一边的世界，而且发现它看起来好得多时，会发生什么？
Let's begin with Melanie, the girl who freaked out. I wondered about Melanie because she had such a strong, immediate reaction that everyone remembered, but also because listen to what happened after that. So apparently, Melanie started crying the moment she got to Fieldston, wanted to leave. But the teachers managed to calm her down. And for a while, it seemed like the moment had passed, and they were fine.
先从那个崩溃的女孩梅兰妮说起。我对梅兰妮感到好奇，因为她有着每个人都记忆犹新的强烈即时反应，而且听听之后发生了什么。显然，梅兰妮在到达菲尔德斯顿的那一刻就开始哭泣，想离开。但老师们设法让她冷静了下来。有那么一会儿，事情似乎过去了，他们表现得还行。
They partnered all the students up, so the University Heights kids could go with the Fieldston kids to some of their classes. Marlena Edelstein, a Fieldston student, told me the girl who shadowed her, she doesn't remember her name. But other people told me it was Melanie. Marlena has never forgotten her.
他们让所有学生两两组队，大学高地的孩子可以跟着菲尔德斯顿的孩子去上课。玛琳娜·埃德尔斯坦（Marlena Edelstein）是菲尔德斯顿的学生，她告诉我那个跟她一起上课的女孩，她不记得名字了，但其他人告诉我那是梅兰妮。玛琳娜从未忘记她。
I remember we were studying the Enlightenment. And we were looking at it through paintings. And I remember her making connections between the painting and Enlightenment era philosophers, and quoting John Locke, and just schooling all of us-- you know, making connections that I would have been completely incapable of making, and just clearly the smartest person in the room.
我记得我们当时在学启蒙运动，通过绘画来观察它。我记得她把这幅画和启蒙时代的哲学家联系起来，引用约翰·洛克的话，简直是在给我们上课……那种联系能力是我完全无法做到的，她显然是房间里最聪明的人。
Then, after wowing everyone in this class with her intellect, Melanie left, ran away. She found the experience of being at Fieldston so upsetting she ultimately could not stand to be there. And Lisa Greenbaum, her teacher, told me Melanie did not just run away from Fieldston that day. She also seemed to run away from high school. She doesn't remember seeing her much after that.
然后，在以智慧惊艳全班后，梅兰妮离开了，跑掉了。她发现待在菲尔德斯顿的经历令她极其痛苦，以至于最终无法忍受待在那里。她的老师丽莎·格林鲍姆告诉我，梅兰妮那天不只是从菲尔德斯顿跑掉了，她似乎还从高中生活里“跑掉”了。她不记得在那之后见过她多少次。
I would love to know-- I would love to know how she feels about who she is and if that moment in her life in any way shaped the way she thinks today.
我很想知道，我很想知道她如何看待自己，以及生命中的那一刻是否以某种方式塑造了她今天的思考方式。
Lisa told me she had no idea where Melanie was. But she said, you know who you should call? Ashleigh Wallace. That was Melanie's best friend. She'll know what happened.
丽莎告诉我她根本不知道梅兰妮在哪里。但她说：“你知道你应该给谁打电话吗？阿什莉·华莱士（Ashleigh Wallace）。那是梅兰妮最好的朋友。她会知道发生了什么。”
So me and Melanie were pissed off.
我和梅兰妮当时气坏了。
What happened?
发生了什么？
We were definitely pissed off. I mean have you ever seen Edward Scissorhands?
我们绝对气坏了。你看过《剪刀手爱德华》吗？
Seen what?
看过什么？
Edward Scissorhands.
《剪刀手爱德华》。
Yeah, yeah.
哦，是的，看过。
And you know how his house is at the top of the hill, and it's all dark and gloomy? And then you have the rest of the town where all the houses are colorful, and it's sunny all day and bright, or whatever the case is? It was just like that. Like we were leaving the Bronx and going into some complete, totally different, Utopian existence.
你知道他的房子在山顶上，又暗又阴沉吗？然后镇上的其他地方，房子都很鲜艳，阳光明媚，很亮，不管情况如何？当时就是那样。就像我们离开了布朗克斯，进入了一个完全不同的乌托邦世界。
You know, Lisa kept telling us while we were pen palling these kids that, oh, they go to a private school, but they're just like us. And just like us is you live in a bad neighborhood like we do. You go to a bullshit, shitty ass school like we do where we have no cafeteria because it's been converted into a classroom.
你知道，丽莎在我们通信时一直对我们说：“噢，他们去的是私立学校，但他们和我们一样。”而“和我们一样”的意思是：你住在这个像我们一样糟糕的社区；你上着像我们一样烂透了的学校，甚至连食堂都没有，因为被改成了教室。
We have a daycare for the mothers who have children. There's-- what? One, two, three floors in our school? She's like, oh, they're just like us. They're nothing like us, nothing at all.
我们学校还有给有孩子的妈妈们准备的托儿所。学校……有什么？三层楼？她竟然说“他们和我们一样”。他们和我们一点都不像，完全不像。
I asked Ashleigh, so where is Melanie now?
我问阿什莉：“那么梅兰妮现在在哪里？”
She actually graduated a little earlier. And I've been looking for her since then because, you know, me and her used to be very, very close.
她其实早一点就毕业了。从那以后我一直在找她，因为你知道，我和她曾经非常非常亲近。
For a while, it seemed like maybe they just lost touch. That happens after high school. Ashleigh's mom moved to Atlanta. Eventually, Ashleigh did too and had a baby.
有段时间，似乎他们只是失去了联系，高中毕业后常发生这种事。阿什莉的妈妈搬到了亚特兰大，后来阿什莉也搬去了，还生了个孩子。
But after a while, it stopped feeling to Ashleigh like the two of them had just drifted apart and started to feel more like Melanie did not want to be found. Her phone number changed. She's nowhere online. Ashleigh has checked Facebook so many times.
但过了一阵子，在阿什莉看来，这感觉不再只是两个人渐行渐远，而更像是梅兰妮不想被找到。她的电话号码换了，网上也找不到人。阿什莉查过很多次Facebook。
My mom always asks about her and stuff, but I could not find her.
我妈妈总是问起她之类的事，但我找不到她。
Do you know if she went to college?
你知道她上大学了吗？
No, I really don't.
不，我真的不知道。
But Ashleigh says she must have. How else does someone disappear like that unless they make it out of the Bronx and never look back? There is a New York City number listed under Melanie's name, but of course--
但阿什莉说她肯定上了。除了逃离布朗克斯且永远不再回头，一个人怎么可能消失成那样呢？在梅兰妮名下有一个纽约市的电话号码，但当然……
--does not accept calls at this time. We're sorry for any inconvenience this may cause.
“……该号码目前不接受来电。由此带来的不便我们深表歉意。”
There's a woman with the same name who manages a real estate firm in Corpus Christi. There's a dental lab technician in Harrisburg, an executive office professional in Las Vegas, a woman on Twitter, who I think lives in Mexico and has devoted her account to retweeting Justin Bieber's Twitter account. They all seem to be about the right age, all not her.
有个同名女子在科珀斯克里斯蒂市经营一家房地产公司；还有个在哈里斯堡工作的牙科实验室技师；拉斯维加斯的一名行政人员；推特上还有一个我想是住在墨西哥的女性，她的账户专门转发贾斯汀·比伯的推文。他们看起来年纪都差不多，但都不是她。
A background check on Melanie's name lists a current and former address. I went to the current one. She does not live there. Sent letters to both-- no luck. Ashleigh, her friend from high school, gave me a couple of names of people she thought might have kept up with Melanie.
对梅兰妮名字的背景调查列出了当前和以前的地址。我去过现在的地址，她不在那儿。给两个地址都寄了信，都没有回音。她在高中的朋友阿什莉给了我几个可能还在和梅兰妮联系的人的名字。
And top of the list was Pablo Muriel, their high school history teacher. He's Puerto Rican, like Melanie, from the neighborhood. Ashleigh says, we all loved Pablo, but especially Melanie.
名单上排第一的是巴勃罗·穆里尔（Pablo Muriel），他们高中的历史老师。他是波多黎各人，和梅兰妮来自同一个街区。阿什莉说，我们都爱巴勃罗，但梅兰妮最爱。
Yes, hello?
喂，你好？
Hi. It's Chana Joffe-Walt, the reporter.
你好，我是记者查娜·乔夫-沃尔特。
Oh, yes, hi. How are you? You caught me at the perfect time. These people calling me into meetings. I was like, oh, thank god. How are you?
噢，你好。你好吗？你打来的时间太巧了。那些人正拉着我去开会，我都快烦死了，感谢老天。你好吗？
Pablo said Melanie is one of those kids you remember because she was very, very, very smart-- three verys-- and full of potential. She stood out to him for other reasons too.
巴勃罗说梅兰妮是那种你会记住的孩子，因为她非常非常非常聪明——用了三个“非常”——而且充满潜力。她因为其他原因也让他印象深刻。
She was a bit out there, like her personality was out there. However, her intellect surpassed most of her peers at the time. Interesting enough, I think she passed by the school to visit maybe four years ago.
她有点另类，性格很外向。然而，她的智力在当时超过了大多数同龄人。有趣的是，我想她大约四年前曾路过学校，回来参观过。
And I remember her coming back with me to say hello to me. And I was with another teacher, sitting down-- I won't forget this day because it was just so odd. She came and spoke to me. And I told her, hold on. I'll talk to you in a minute. I think she took it as me brushing her off, and she just kind of stormed out. And I never saw her again.
我记得她回来跟我打招呼，我当时正和另一位老师坐着——那天我永远不会忘，因为太奇怪了。她过来跟我说话，我告诉她：“等等，我一会儿跟你说。”我想她以为我在敷衍她，她就那样气呼呼地走了。我再也没见过她。
You were just busy and like, happy to see you, just hang on a second?
你当时只是太忙，而且很高兴见到她，让她等一会儿？
Yeah. Yeah, because it was she caught me between classes. Hi, Pablo. I'm like, oh, hey, Melanie. Hold on. I'll talk to you in a minute. And then she just said, OK, whatever. And she just left. And I never saw her again.
是的，是的，因为她是课间把我截住了。她说“嗨，巴勃罗”，我当时说“噢，嘿，梅兰妮，等等，我一会儿跟你说”。然后她就说“好吧，随便”，然后就走了。我再也没见过她。
I began contacting former classmates. And I became sort of obsessed because it was weird how invisible she was. Everyone else was super easy to find. These are 25-year-olds, and we have the internet.
我开始联系以前的同学。我变得有些着迷，因为她消失得如此彻底，这很奇怪。其他人都很容易找到。他们都是25岁的人，而且我们有互联网。
And the classmates' memories of Melanie were all similarly mythic. She spoke her mind. She was brilliant. She was fierce. She was going to make it. And no one had heard from her.
同学对梅兰妮的记忆都带有某种神话色彩。她直言不讳，非常聪明，极其犀利。她本来会成功的。但没一个人有她的消息。
Weirdly, the one person I contacted who had a real idea of what happened to Melanie was the teacher from Fieldston, the private school, Angela Vassos. Someone told me Angela had taken a special interest in Melanie after she got so upset at Fieldston. And a decade later, when I met Angela and first asked about Melanie, she started crying.
奇怪的是，我联系到的唯一一个真正知道梅兰妮发生了什么的人，是菲尔德斯顿私立学校的老师安吉拉·瓦索斯。有人告诉我，在梅兰妮从菲尔德斯顿回来后变得那么沮丧，安吉拉对她产生了特殊的兴趣。十年后，当我见到安吉拉第一次问起梅兰妮时，她哭了。
I'm sorry. It's just Melanie's--
对不起，只是梅兰妮她……
No problem.
没关系。
[INAUDIBLE], you know? There's a part of me I guess--
（听不清），你知道吗？我想我内心有一部分……
Angela got a box of tissues, then sat down.
安吉拉拿了一盒纸巾，然后坐下。
I had a real soft spot for that kid. I still have a soft spot for that kid. She was smart, really smart. I don't know if she realized. She knew she was powerful, but I don't know if she knew she was smart.
我对那孩子有一种特别的偏爱。我现在依然如此。她很聪明，真的非常聪明。我不知道她自己有没有意识到。她知道自己有影响力，但我不知道她是否知道自己很聪明。
After that first encounter at Fieldston, Angela tried hard to gain Melanie's trust. I think she felt partially responsible. And she really wanted to help Melanie, even though she wasn't Melanie's teacher.
在那次菲尔德斯顿的初次相遇后，安吉拉极力想赢得梅兰妮的信任。我想她觉得有部分责任。虽然她不是梅兰妮的老师，但她真心想帮助梅兰妮。
The program kept going throughout the year. Angela would bring her private school students over to the public school. And sometimes she'd visit on her own. And every time, she'd make a special point to check in on Melanie. The last time Angela ever saw Melanie was in the public school. Angela was over there visiting, and Lillian, the college advisor, comes in.
那个项目全年都在进行。安吉拉会把她的私立学校学生带到公立学校。有时她会独自去参观。每一次，她都会特意去看看梅兰妮。安吉拉最后一次见到梅兰妮是在那所公立学校里。当时安吉拉在那里访问，负责大学咨询的莉莲（Lillian）走了进来。
She walked in. And Melanie was really on a tear about white bitches and they don't know anything about the world. And Lillian walks in, and she waves a piece of paper. And she says, Melanie, come here. Melanie goes up. There are like 50 people in the room.
她走了进来。梅兰妮当时正因为“那些白人贱人一无所知”而大发雷霆。莉莲走了进来，挥着一张纸说：“梅兰妮，过来。”梅兰妮走过去。房间里有50人。
She says, Middlebury accepted you, full scholarship. And Melanie started crying. I started crying. We all did. We were so excited. And Lillian, she says, we made it. We made it. We made it. You know? Incredible news. And Middlebury, we're talking about a serious, serious school-- full scholarship.
她说：“明德学院录取你了，全额奖学金。”梅兰妮开始哭，我也开始哭，大家都哭了。我们太激动了。莉莲说：“我们做到了，我们做到了！”你知道吗？难以置信的消息。而且明德学院（Middlebury），那可是所非常非常厉害的学校，全额奖学金。
And Melanie buried her face in Lillian's shoulder here. And they hugged for such a long time, not one of these hugs. It must have been a two-minute hug. And Lillian was swinging her around. And Melanie had her arms around her. And I thought, that's so great. And you knew at that moment-- it was moving because you knew at that moment Melanie felt safe.
梅兰妮把脸埋在莉莲肩膀里。她们拥抱了很久，不是那种敷衍的拥抱。一定持续了两分钟。莉莲转着圈抱着她，梅兰妮也环抱着她。我想，这太棒了。你在那一刻就知道——这一幕很感人，因为你知道在那一刻梅兰妮感到了安全。
And that's when Melanie disappeared. Because she did not finish the last month of the year. She disappeared. To this day, they don't know where she is. She probably just got scared. You know?
然后梅兰妮就消失了。因为她没有完成那一年的最后一个月。她消失了。直到今天，他们都不知道她在哪里。她可能只是被吓坏了，你知道吗？
Wait. She got into Middlebury, but she didn't go?
等等。她被明德学院录取了，但没去？
She didn't finish the last month of school either. She left.
她连高中的最后一个月都没念完。她离开了。
Oh, wow.
噢，天哪。
Yeah. Literally disappeared. No one could find her.
是的。真的消失了。没人找得到她。
I called Middlebury to see if maybe Melanie did attend. They said, no. Did she get in? They said, we have no record showing that she received an offer of admission. I didn't know if that meant she wasn't admitted, or they just had no record either way, but that's all they would say.
我打电话给明德学院，想查查梅兰妮是否真的去读过。他们说：“没有。”“那她被录取了吗？”他们说：“我们没有任何关于她收到录取通知的记录。”我不知道这是否意味着她没有被录取，或者是他们确实没有任何记录，但他们只肯说这么多。
And this was strange because Angela had such a vivid memory of Melanie getting in. And Angela herself went to Middlebury, so she probably didn't mix up the name of the college. Plus, the college advisor at Melanie's school seemed to remember it.
这很奇怪，因为安吉拉对梅兰妮被录取这件事记忆如此清晰，而且安吉拉本人就是明德学院毕业的，所以她不太可能搞错大学的名字。此外，梅兰妮学校的大学顾问似乎也记得这件事。
So at this point, I went back to Melanie's high school friend, Ashleigh, and just asked if it sounded like Melanie to psych herself out like that. And she said, no way. I only made it to my GED, but Melanie was singularly focused on college. She'd curse me out when I cut class.
所以这时候，我回去找了梅兰妮的高中好友阿什莉，问她梅兰妮是否会像那样自乱阵脚。她说：“绝对不会。我连高中毕业证都没拿到，但梅兰妮是铁了心要上大学的。当我逃课时，她会骂我。”
When it came down to me and her, I was what she was trying to avoid.
当我和她在一起时，我是她试图避免变成的样子。
Melanie was not going to fail at high school. She would go to college with no babies and live far, far from New York City, period.
梅兰妮绝不会在高中失败。她要去读大学，不生孩子，住在离纽约市很远很远的地方，句号。
You can say things like, when is my recycling picked up? Or report a noisy neighbor. Go ahead.
你可以说些话，比如：垃圾什么时候回收？或者举报吵闹的邻居。请讲。
Death record.
死亡记录。
All right. I can help you learn how to request a certificate for a death reported in the city.
好的，我可以教你如何申请报告在该市发生的死亡证明。
I didn't think Melanie was dead, but a friend asked. And once that seed was planted, I could not get the idea out of my head. The same day I went in person to the city's office for vital records, I also went to an old address listed on a background check, one I'd sent letters to.
我不认为梅兰妮死了，但有个朋友问过。一旦那个念头种下，我就挥之不去。去市政府获取人口记录的那天，我也去了背景调查里列出的一个旧地址，就是我寄过信的那个。
I don't think she lives here anymore.
我想她不在这里住了。
The buzzer didn't have Melanie's name on it, and I pressed it anyway. No answer. Stood by the door to the building.
门铃上没有梅兰妮的名字，但我还是按了。没人回答。我站在楼门口。
Hey.
嘿。
Do you know somebody named Melanie?
你认识一个叫梅兰妮的人吗？
Yes, that's my girlfriend, actually.
认识，其实她是我女朋友。
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Oh.
噢。
You've been searching for her, I see.
我看你一直在找她。
I have.
是的。
She got your letters. She's actually at work.
她收到了你的信。她现在去上班了。
That's his girlfriend. She's at work.
那是他女朋友。她去上班了。
She's just-- she's been busy for school and work.
她只是……最近忙着学习和工作。
Yeah.
是的。
She hasn't really got a chance to reach out to you.
她还没机会联系你。
And she did get my letters.
而且她确实收到了我的信。
Yeah. She got your letters.
是的，她收到了。
Oh, great.
噢，太好了。
Mm-hm. Mm-hm.
嗯，嗯。
I'm so glad I asked you. What's your name?
很高兴问了你。你叫什么名字？
[INAUDIBLE] to ask. Jonathan.
（听不清）乔纳森（Jonathan）。
I'm Chana. Nice to meet you.
我是查娜。很高兴认识你。
He told me she'd call when she got off work. He didn't want to tell me anything more. But he did tell me Melanie worked at a supermarket on Sixth Avenue. It happens to be around the corner from my office. It took three days for Melanie to call me. And when she did, she carefully said, I've given this a lot of thought, and I'm ready to talk.
他告诉我她下班后会打给我。他不想透露更多信息。但他告诉我梅兰妮在第六大道的一家超市工作，就在我办公室拐角处。梅兰妮过了三天才给我打电话。她小心翼翼地说：“我考虑了很多，我准备好聊聊了。”
I can't believe you're here.
真不敢相信你在这儿。
[LAUGHS] I can't believe I'm here.
（笑）真不敢相信我在这儿。
Yeah? Are you nervous?
是吗？你紧张吗？
I mean, I looked on the website. I mean, it's probably something that people are going to hear, people are going to listen to. If they could see me, they'd know I'm different. You know I'm different. I'm sitting here with like blue-green hair. [LAUGHS]
我的意思是，我看了网站。这可能是人们会听到的，人们会去听的。如果他们能看到我，他们就知道我变了。你知道我变了。我坐在这儿，顶着一头蓝绿色的头发。（笑）
She's also wearing pink sweatpants and a hoodie. Her hair is actually under a hat, so all I can see are some green bangs peeking out. The "they" she's talking about, that's you listening right now. Melanie has considered you a lot-- who you are, how you'll hear her.
她还穿着粉红色的运动裤和连帽衫。她的头发实际上藏在帽子下面，所以我只能看到一点绿色的刘海露出来。她所说的“他们”，就是此时正在听节目的你们。梅兰妮考虑了很多关于你们的事——你们是谁，你们会怎么听。
I asked Melanie about the visit to Fieldston pretty early on in our conversation, but her answer began with her first day of high school. She says she was just one of those kids who always loved school. She got good grades, and she'd been anticipating high school years before she got there. She had a clear image in her mind of how exciting it would be. She'd become a better writer, read, read, and read, and go to games, maybe join the dance team. And her first day of freshman year--
我在交谈初期就问了梅兰妮关于参观菲尔德斯顿的事，但她的回答始于她高中的第一天。她说她一直是个热爱学校的孩子。她成绩优异，在进高中前几年就一直很期待。她脑海中清楚地映现着这会有多令人兴奋：她会成为更好的作家，博览群书，去参加比赛，或许还会加入舞蹈队。但在高一第一天……
Well, I remember going in. And I was just like, what is this? You know? Like, this has got to be a joke.
好吧，我记得走进去时，我心想：这是什么鬼？这肯定是在开玩笑吧。
Wait. The school felt like a joke?
等等。这所学校感觉像个笑话？
Yeah, completely. I was sitting in the classroom with seniors when I was a freshman. They didn't even have a math B course.
是的，完全是。我高一时是和高三学生一起上课。他们甚至都没有开设数学B课程。
What's math B? I don't know what that is.
什么是数学B？我不知道那是什么。
It's like the second level to math A, I would say prior to taking trigonometry or even statistics or something like that. They don't offer any AP classes. Another thing that was really tormenting to me was that we didn't have a library. And I love books. This is like, wow, we're really in a poor part of the Bronx where we're not being considered.
我想那是在学习三角学或统计学之类的课程之前的第二级数学。他们不提供任何AP课程。另一件让我非常折磨的事是我们没有图书馆。我热爱书籍。这就好比是：哇，我们真的身处布朗克斯一个贫穷的地方，这里根本没把我们当回事。
Then, in 10th grade, Melanie's English teacher said they were going to start a pen pal program with a school called Fieldston. Melanie was open to it. She wrote a sincere letter describing herself and her dreams and climbed onto the bus with the rest of her classmates to go to Fieldston.
然后高二时，梅兰妮的英语老师说要和一个叫菲尔德斯顿的学校开展笔友计划。梅兰妮并不排斥。她写了一封诚挚的信描述自己和梦想，然后和同学一起上了巴士去了菲尔德斯顿。
So what happened when you went there?
那你去那儿时发生了什么？
When we went there, we looked like a bunch of hooligans. I would say we looked like the goonies walking in a Wall Street building. I felt like you knew we weren't from there. Like, who are these ghetto kids walking in? We just-- we knew we didn't fit in. We didn't look like the rest of the students. It was a very organized school.
当我们去的时候，我们看起来就像一群无赖。我会说我们就像走进华尔街大楼的傻瓜。我觉得你们知道我们不是那儿的人。就像：这些“贫民窟”孩子走进来是要干嘛？我们只是……我们知道自己不合群。我们看起来不像其他学生。那是一所秩序井然的学校。
Wait. What did you look like? What do you mean when you [INAUDIBLE].
等等，你们看起来像什么？你指的（听不清）是什么意思？
Well, when I went there, I had bright red hair, cherry red like Charli Baltimore, which was a female rapper at that time. I had my nails super long, out here, really colorful, like 20 colors on them. All of us wore Jordans. Everybody in the hood, oh, Jordans is the big thing. You could tell. You knew off the back these students are not from this school.
嗯，我去那里时染着亮红色的头发，像当时的女说唱歌手查理·巴尔的摩（Charli Baltimore）那样鲜艳。指甲留得超长，非常显眼，上面涂了大概20种颜色。我们都穿着乔丹鞋。在贫民区，每个人都觉得乔丹鞋是很重要的。你一看就知道这些学生不是这所学校的。
What did you feel like that day?
那天你感觉如何？
I felt like a ratchet ass girl from the hood. I felt like I didn't belong there. I just felt like I have no business in this building. I don't remember them. They were just like a sea of white, blond, blue-green eyes. I couldn't possibly bring myself into my body to actually engage with these kids. I didn't want to engage with them.
我觉得自己就像个来自底层的没教养的女孩。我觉得我不属于那儿。我只是觉得我不该出现在这栋楼里。我不记得他们了，他们就像一片白人，金发，蓝绿色的眼睛。我无法让自己真正去和这些孩子互动。我不想和他们互动。
For so many University Heights kids I talked to, seeing Fieldston was shocking because of the stark difference. It was a surprise. They could not have imagined a place like Fieldston. For Melanie, it wasn't that. Melanie had imagined it.
对我聊过的很多大学高地的孩子来说，看到菲尔德斯顿是令人震惊的，因为那种强烈的差异。这是一种冲击。他们根本无法想象菲尔德斯顿那样的地方。对梅兰妮来说并非如此，她已经想象过了。
This was what I envisioned as high school, what these kids are experiencing. This is what I wanted to see myself going to as a high school experience.
这就是我心中想象的高中，这些孩子正在经历的。这就是我想象中自己高中的样子。
Oh, that's what you expected high school to be.
噢，这就是你预期的高中样子。
Yeah, definitely.
是的，绝对是。
So you didn't-- what felt surprising to you was just like, this is the first time that I'm seeing the thing in real life that I thought was what I was going to walk into in ninth grade?
所以让你感到惊讶的只是……这是你第一次亲眼看到你以为高一进门就会看到的东西？
Yep. And it was just like, OK, this is private. So this is-- everything kind of is a fucking lie that you see your whole life growing up on TV shows or movies. It's like, OK, this is not free. This is not available for kids of color. This is something that only privileged or the elite can have.
是的。感觉就像：好吧，这就是私立学校。所以……你从小在电视节目或电影里看到的一切，都是他妈的谎言。你会想：好吧，这不是免费的。这不是给有色人种孩子准备的。这是只有特权阶层或精英才能拥有的。
I know I looked at it and I said, well, I know that we're only being taught to flip burgers in Burger King or McDonald's or to hold doors for students like them that will probably live in those buildings on Madison Avenue. And we'll be wearing the uniform servicing these people.
我知道我看着它说，好吧，我知道我们只被教导去汉堡王或麦当劳翻肉饼，或者是为像他们那样的学生开门，那些人可能会住在麦迪逊大道的建筑里，而我们穿着制服服务这些人。
You thought that when you were at Fieldston?
你在菲尔德斯顿时这么想的？
Definitely.
绝对是。
Whoa. That's wild.
哇，这太狂野了。
So it was like when the shit hits the fan.
所以当情况变糟时就是这种感觉。
So you imagined this is--
所以你想象这就是……
The future, yeah.
未来，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
Seeing what we would all be like as adults.
看到我们成年后都会变成什么样子。
So that's what she found so upsetting. It seemed that the people around her must believe that this was the natural order of things. Melanie knew there was no innate difference between her and a kid born into wealth. She could see that this division we're all so inured to was not a reflection of her inferior worth or ability. She just didn't know what to do with the idea that she might be alone in seeing that.
这就是让她感到如此沮丧的原因。周围的人似乎都认为这是自然的秩序。梅兰妮知道她和一个生来富有的人之间没有本质区别。她看得出我们都习以为常的这种分裂，并不是她能力或价值低下的体现。她只是不知道该怎么处理这种感觉：似乎只有她一个人能看透这一点。
But Melanie had her own plan after Fieldston, as soon as she could get out of high school. And her plan did not involve holding doors. She had enough credits to graduate high school early, as a junior.
但梅兰妮在菲尔德斯顿之行后有了自己的计划，只要她能尽快逃离高中。而她的计划不包括为别人开门。她有足够的学分，可以作为高三学生提前毕业。
So I just want to hurry up and get my high school diploma to say, here, I'm educated. I got it. I want to get into a four-year school. I already sold myself with a master's degree, which means 16 to 24, eight years. Yep. Check.
所以我只是想赶紧拿到高中毕业证书说：“给，我受过教育。我拿到了。”我想去读四年制大学。我已经给自己设想好了硕士学位，意味着从16岁到24岁，八年。是的，搞定。
Melanie's vision was so clear. And the adults around her could see it too. Pablo Muriel, the teacher, and all the teachers at her school knew their job was to fill in the gaps, make up for the fact that Melanie did not get to be a Fieldston kid and get her to college anyway.
梅兰妮的愿景非常清晰。周围的大人们也能看出来。巴勃罗·穆里尔老师和她学校的所有老师都知道，他们的职责是填补空白，弥补梅兰妮没能成为菲尔德斯顿孩子的事实，总之要送她上大学。
So a few months before graduation, the high school guidance counselor nominated Melanie for something called a Posse scholarship. The Posse Foundation sends kids from 10 cities to private, elite colleges, full scholarship-- schools like Cornell, Dartmouth, and Middlebury. Melanie had her eyes set on Middlebury, just like Angela Vassos remembered. And the thing that could get her there was the Posse scholarship.
所以在毕业前几个月，高中升学顾问提名梅兰妮参加一个叫“Posse”的奖学金项目。Posse基金会从10个城市挑选孩子送往精英私立大学，全额奖学金，比如康奈尔、达特茅斯和明德学院。梅兰妮一心想要去明德学院，正如安吉拉·瓦索斯所记得的那样。能让她去那儿的东西就是Posse奖学金。
It's really competitive. There's hundreds of kids all over New York City in this one floor of a building that you go to.
竞争非常激烈。纽约市成百上千个孩子都在一栋楼的同一个楼层里参加面试。
Do you remember what you wore?
你记得你穿了什么吗？
I think the first day, I wore high heels and a skirt. Maybe I wore a tie with a shirt, a dress-up shirt. I always went very professional when I went there, like what is considered office apparel.
我想第一天我穿了高跟鞋和裙子。也许还戴了领带，穿了正式衬衫。我去那儿时总是穿得很专业，就像所谓的办公室正装。
Posse sends groups of kids to college together, a posse. And they're trying to choose kids who would otherwise be missed because their test scores aren't great, or because they go to bad schools. After the first round, half the students get called back, the next round, half the remaining students. Then that group gets cut again.
Posse把一群孩子一起送进大学，形成一个“队伍”。他们试图挑选那些原本会被错过的人，因为他们的标准化成绩不是特别高，或者是来自糟糕的学校。经过第一轮，一半学生被召回；下一轮，剩下一半学生的一半被召回。然后那组人再次被筛选。
Trying to figure out how to get into college is stressful for everyone. But for most people, it does not look like reality TV.
试图弄清楚怎么进大学对每个人来说都很压力大。但对大多数人来说，这看起来不像是真人秀。
I kept getting put to the next stage. And each time you go back, they just send you a letter in the mail letting you know, OK, you made it through the next round. We expect you here at this day, this time. The final time is when you meet the college.
我不断进入下一阶段。每次回去，他们只是寄信通知我，好吧，你进了下一轮。我们期待你在某天某时出现。最后一次是和大学面对面面试。
Middlebury. Do you remember what they asked you in the interview?
明德学院。你还记得面试时他们问了你什么吗？
No, I don't.
不，我不记得了。
Were you nervous?
你紧张吗？
I was nervous, very nervous.
我很紧张，非常紧张。
This year, I sat in on the Posse finalist interviews. And I can tell you that by this point in the process, the only kids left in the room could do your job with a week of training. We were sitting in this room with 25 amazing kids. 15 of them were about to get voted off the island. They get a letter, like Melanie did, saying no.
今年，我参加了Posse的决赛面试。我可以告诉你，到了这个环节，房间里剩下的孩子每一个都有能力直接去胜任你的工作。我们坐在那个房间里，面对25个了不起的孩子，其中15个即将被淘汰。他们会像梅兰妮一样收到一封信，说“不”。
Unfortunately, you didn't get picked. I believe I still have that letter hiding somewhere.
不幸的是，你没有被选中。我想那封信现在还藏在什么地方。
Melanie did not get in. She made it to the very last round. But in the end, she did not get it.
梅兰妮没被录取。她撑到了最后一轮，但最终没有拿到。
I don't know why Angela Vassos remembers Melanie getting into Middlebury, except that what she and the school college counselor must be remembering is the moment Melanie was selected as a finalist, because that would have been an exciting moment. And it would make sense that they did not know the very last step-- that in the end, Melanie did not make it-- because they never saw her again. They couldn't have known seeing Fieldston was not what made Melanie want to run away, it was this.
我不知道为什么安吉拉·瓦索斯会记得梅兰妮被明德学院录取了，也许她和学校的大学顾问所记忆的是梅兰妮入选决赛的那一刻，因为那会是一个令人激动的时刻。他们没能得知最后一步——梅兰妮最终没能入选——也是合理的，因为他们再也没见过她。他们不可能知道，梅兰妮想跑掉的原因不是因为参观了菲尔德斯顿，而是因为这个。
You go through something to just get turned down. It's a waste too. It's like, would you have been better off not going through this experience?
你经历了一切，结果却被拒绝了。这也像是一种浪费。就好像：如果不经历这种体验，你会不会更好过一些？
Is that how you feel?
你感觉是这样吗？
I mean, maybe I would have been better off not going through that experience. Once that happened, I just wrote it off out of my life.
我的意思是，也许我不去经历那种体验会更好。一旦那件事发生了，我就把它从我的生活中抹去了。
Because it's too painful?
因为太痛苦了？
I think because it's just a moment of disappointment.
我想是因为那只是一个让你失望的时刻。
Yeah, I can see that.
是的，我明白。
Mm-hm. (EMOTIONAL) It's like a really beautiful thing if you do get it. At least that's the way it looked. But what you put children through to get there is hard to then be turned down and say, why didn't I get it? What was wrong with me?
（情绪激动）如果你拿到了，那是一件非常美妙的事。至少看起来是这样。但让孩子们经历这一切，最终却被拒绝，反问自己：为什么我没拿到？我有什么问题？
Melanie could see an elite college was a long shot, especially for a kid from a poor public school. But she was going to make it because she was exceptional. Her teachers saw it. She knew it. That was the ground she stood on-- until this moment.
梅兰妮明白精英大学机会渺茫，尤其是对一个贫困公立学校的孩子来说。但她会成功的，因为她出类拔萃。她的老师看到了，她自己也知道。这就是她立足的基础——直到那一刻。
You know, maybe you were just somebody exceptional because of the environment you were in, not necessarily because you are exceptional. People'd be like, oh, you're so smart. You're going to be this. You're going to be that. You're going to be somebody. You're going to change the world. You're going to-- and it's like, be realistic.
你知道，也许你只是因为身处的环境才显得出类拔萃，而不一定是因为你本身出类拔萃。人们会说：“噢，你真聪明，你会成为这个，你会成为那个，你会成为某个重要人物，你会改变世界。”然后你会想：现实点吧。
You know, Pablo wanted me to apply for Harvard. I was like, be fucking realistic. I'm never going to get accepted to Harvard. This is a school that doesn't even have fucking statistics offered, you know, like AP classes. Versus a kid like Fieldston-- you walk out in four years, you're prepared to go to a school like that.
你知道，巴勃罗想让我申请哈佛，我说：“他妈的现实点。我永远进不了哈佛。这是一所连基本的统计学课程都没提供，没有AP课程的学校。而对比菲尔德斯顿那样的孩子，四年后他们出门就准备好进入那种学校了。”
This is not happening for me. I don't think anything is going to change that. After that, I definitely knew that I wanted to run out of that high school as fast as possible. And I ended up graduating spring semester of that year, and I was gone. So--
这不会发生在我身上。我不认为有什么能改变这点。在那之后，我绝对知道我想尽快逃离那所高中。我最后在那年的春季学期毕业，然后我就走了。所以……
Really gone.
真的走了。
Yeah, really gone. Gone.
是的，真的走了。走了。
Like off the map gone.
像是彻底消失了。
Yep. This has to be her.
是的。这一定是她。
(ON PHONE) Hi, Melanie. This is Lisa. I taught you English--
（电话中）嗨，梅兰妮，我是丽莎。我教过你英语——
I was walking with Melanie one day recently when she played a voicemail for me she got from Lisa Greenbaum, her old high school teacher. I hadn't given Lisa Melanie's number. I hadn't even told her yet about being in touch. It turned out just a few days before, Melanie had called the front desk of the high school to get a copy of her diploma, and people from the school started getting back in touch.
最近我和梅兰妮散步时，她给我播放了一段她从高中老师丽莎·格林鲍姆那收到的语音留言。我没有给丽莎梅兰妮的号码，甚至没告诉她我已经联系上了梅兰妮。结果就在几天前，梅兰妮打给高中前台想补办一份毕业证，学校的人就开始联系她了。
(ON PHONE) I would love to hear what's going on with you. Call me when you can.
（电话中）我很想知道你现在过得怎么样。有空给我回个电话。
Melanie is shaking her head, listening.
梅兰妮一边听一边摇头。
(ON PHONE) Loking forward to talking to you. Bye bye.
（电话中）期待能和你通话。拜拜。
Are you going to call her back?
你会回电吗？
Uh, probably, by the end of the week.
呃，可能吧，这周结束前。
No, you're not. Are you going to?
不，你不会。你会吗？
No, I'll probably call. I just want to go about my business, do what I got to do for myself.
不，我可能会打吧。我只是想过好我的生活，做我该为自己做的事。
In other words, yeah, absolutely not. Melanie never called Lisa.
换句话说，完全不会。梅兰妮从没回给丽莎。
I'm surprised that my number even got passed to these people. They're just calling because I happened to call the school. It's not like anybody's really reaching out to me.
我很惊讶我的号码竟然传给了这些人。他们只是因为我碰巧打给学校才打电话来。又不是真的有人主动关心我。
This, of course, makes no sense. Somebody calling your mobile device and saying, I would love to hear what's going on with you, that's the definition of someone reaching out. But this is where Melanie is right now.
这当然完全讲不通。有人拨打你的移动设备，说“我很想知道你过得怎么样”，这就是主动关心某人的定义。但这正是梅兰妮现在的状态。
For the last decade of her life, she's been working at the supermarket, taking local college courses part-time, stopping every few semesters when she needs money or sleep, and thinking about where she went wrong. She didn't apply to any other private colleges after Middlebury turned her down. She did not reach out to Lisa, or Pablo, or Ashleigh, or Angela. She graduated early and checked out of high school. And she's furious at herself for doing that.
过去十年里，她一直在这家超市工作，兼职修一些当地大学的课程，每隔几个学期需要钱或休息时就会停下来，反思自己哪里做错了。在明德学院拒绝她后，她没有申请任何其他私立大学。她没有联系丽莎、巴勃罗、阿什莉或安吉拉。她提前毕业，切断了与高中的联系。而且她对自己这样做感到愤怒。
I accepted it, basically. And I guess I just grew very angry with myself for making that choice of saying, well, I'm going to accept this, instead of fighting against it or maybe bringing change into that situation. But I didn't, I accepted it. That's always in the back of my head. Like I know I fucked that up, because I could have probably gotten something out of that extra year of school.
我基本上接受了它。我想我对自己做出那个选择感到非常生气：说“好吧，我要接受这一切”，而不是去反抗或者尝试改变那种状况。但我没有，我接受了。这一点总是在我脑海深处萦绕。就像我知道我搞砸了，因为如果多留一年学校，我可能会得到点什么。
What would you have gotten?
你会得到什么？
I don't know. What if I would have reached out? What if-- what if they would have sent me to CUNY for free college courses? There could have been another opportunity. I just didn't-- I got so frustrated to the point that I didn't want to look for that opportunity. It was just like, I want this shit over and done with because I felt like it wasn't going to change.
我不知道。如果我主动寻求帮助呢？如果……如果他们送我去市立大学（CUNY）修免费大学课程呢？可能会有其他机会。我只是没有……我太沮丧了，甚至不想去寻找那个机会。就像是：我只想让这一切赶紧结束，因为我觉得它不会改变。
So now, a high school teacher who remembers Melanie as having so much promise is calling and wanting to catch up. Of course, Melanie doesn't want to return that call.
所以现在，一位记得梅兰妮拥有无限前途的高中老师打来电话想叙旧。当然，梅兰妮不想回那个电话。
So for you to have people tell you you're exceptional or for me to say people remember you as being very smart, it's just sort of like salt on a wound or something? It just--
所以对你来说，人们告诉你你很出类拔萃，或者我说人们记得你非常聪明，这就像是在伤口上撒盐一样？
I don't-- yeah. How do I measure that intelligence? It's very hard to deal with.
我……是的。我该怎么衡量那种智力？这真的很难处理。
Had you gone to Middlebury, do you think you would believe that you are smart?
如果你去了明德学院，你觉得你会相信自己很聪明吗？
Um, yeah. Why not?
嗯，会吧。为什么不呢？
Just like she felt when she visited Fieldston that first time, Melanie can sense a better, alternate reality sitting right there next to her today-- an alternate reality where she went to college, and her life is totally different.
就像她第一次参观菲尔德斯顿时那样，梅兰妮今天依然能感觉到身边存在着另一个更好的现实——另一个她上了大学，生活完全不同的平行现实。
Chana Joffe-Walt. Coming up, we meet that alternate reality, Melanie if she went to college. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特。接下来，我们要见证那个平行现实，也就是如果梅兰妮上了大学会怎样。在一分钟后的芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Three Miles. Chana Joffe-Walt is looking at a group of students who shared one small experience. They're students from a public school in the Bronx who took field trips three miles up the road to visit one of New York's fanciest private schools.
欢迎收听《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是《三英里》。查娜·乔夫-沃尔特正在关注一群共享过一段小经历的学生。他们来自布朗克斯的一所公立学校，曾驱车三英里去参观纽约最顶尖的私立学校之一。
In the first half of our program, we heard from Melanie, who thinks that if she had gone to college, it would have made all the difference in her life. In this half of the show, we're going to look at whether or not that's true. A lot of kids from her public high school, University Heights High School, lived the life that she did not. They did go to college, two thirds of them last year. Again, here's Chana Joffe-Walt.
在节目的上半部分，我们听到了梅兰妮的故事，她认为如果自己上了大学，生活会完全不同。在这后半部分，我们将看看事实是否如此。来自她公立高中——大学高地高中的很多孩子，活出了她没能活出的生活。他们确实上了大学，去年三分之二的学生都去了。再次请出查娜·乔夫-沃尔特。
I've been talking to lots of University Heights graduates. And I've had this experience a couple times where I feel like I'm speaking to Melanie's alternate reality. The year after Melanie graduated, a handsome, young, black University Heights senior named Jonathan Gonzales won the Posse scholarship.
我和许多大学高地的毕业生聊过。我有几次经历，感觉就像在和“梅兰妮的平行现实”说话。在梅兰妮毕业后的那一年，一个英俊的大学高地黑人毕业生乔纳森·冈萨雷斯（Jonathan Gonzales）赢得了Posse奖学金。
This is a kid who grew up in Melanie's neighborhood, went to her school, was one of only a dozen or so kids picked to be part of the program with Fieldston. And he won the Posse scholarship Melanie so desperately wanted. If anyone is alternate reality Melanie, it is Jonathan. But this is not a role Jonathan conveniently slots into.
这是一个在梅兰妮街区长大、上同一所学校的孩子，是十几名被选入菲尔德斯顿交流项目的孩子之一。他赢得了梅兰妮梦寐以求的Posse奖学金。如果说谁是平行现实版的梅兰妮，那就是乔纳森。但乔纳森并不是顺理成章地扮演这个角色。
I didn't really-- for myself, I didn't really see college. For myself, I saw just not being a homeless guy.
我不……对我自己来说，我真的没想过大学。我眼里的自己，只是别变成个无家可归的人。
At 15 years old, Melanie could see a future with college and graduate school. Not only that, everyone around her could see it too. This is not what people saw for Jonathan. This is not what Jonathan saw for Jonathan.
15岁时，梅兰妮能看到大学和研究生的未来。不仅如此，她周围的所有人都看得到。这并不是人们对乔纳森的看法，也不是乔纳森对自己的看法。
I didn't have a drive to go to college.
我根本没有上大学的动力。
Why not?
为什么？
I-- it was never-- you know, what I thought of myself in the future was being a janitor because I was waking up Saturday mornings, mopping the house, cleaning ceiling fans, sweeping the floor, washing dishes, whatever, what have you. That was what I was experienced in. So college was like I don't know what I would do there. And I had the blessing to have a girlfriend that was into the books.
我……这从未……你知道，我对自己未来的设想是当个清洁工，因为我周六早上醒来就是拖地、清扫吊扇、擦地板、洗碗，无论是什么，这些是我有经验的事。所以对于大学，我不知道我在那儿能做什么。我当时有幸拥有一个热爱阅读的女友。
Raquel Hardy. I wish you could see Jonathan's face when he talks about Raquel. I know that's a corny thing to say. I promise, if you could see it, you'd forget to be so cool. Jonathan says he's loved Raquel basically as long as he can remember.
拉克尔·哈迪（Raquel Hardy）。我真希望你能看到乔纳森谈论拉克尔时的表情。我知道这话说起来很老套。但我保证，如果你看到了，你一定会忘记装深沉。乔纳森说他基本上从记得事起就爱着拉克尔。
Pretty long time. I've known her since I was 12. My junior high school teacher actually said that we would be married. I guess she saw it from, you know, the way we looked at each other or spent time with each other in the classroom. And we always played it down like, nah, no.
好长时间了。我12岁就认识她了。我的初中老师甚至说过我们会结婚。我想她是从我们互相对视的样子或者在教室里消磨时间的方式看出来的。我们总是轻描淡写地说：“不，不会的。”
But that summer right before high school, Raquel and Jonathan got together. And it stopped feeling like a joke that they might just stay together. Jonathan and Raquel both found being at home stressful. Jonathan was given up to foster care as a baby. His foster mom adopted him. He says she loved him, but she could be very cruel.
但在高中前夕的那个夏天，拉克尔和乔纳森在一起了。他们可能会一直在一起，这不再感觉像个笑话。拉克尔和乔纳森都觉得家里很压抑。乔纳森还是婴儿时就被送进了寄养家庭，他的养母收养了他。他说她爱他，但她可以非常残忍。
I was very-- I held a lot of things in. And the way I got them out was by sometimes punching a wall, or punching other people, or getting into fights, or acting out in the classroom. And for Raquel, she was into school. I think her outlet was doing work, being in the books, so she didn't have to think about it. And my outlet was thinking about it, being sad about it, and not speaking to anybody, and just being quiet. [LAUGHS]
我非常……我心里憋了很多事。我发泄的方式有时是打墙，打别人，或者打架，或者在课堂上捣乱。而拉克尔，她喜欢学校。我想她的出口是做作业，泡在书里，这样她就不用去想这些事。我的出口是去思考这些，为之难过，谁也不说话，只是安静地待着。（笑）
I think that's called having no outlet.
我想那叫“没有出口”。
Yeah, having no outlet, OK. [LAUGHS] But yeah, so that was our coping mechanisms.
是的，没有出口，好吧。（笑）但确实，那就是我们应对的方式。
We were best friends. I don't know. It was great.
我们是最好的朋友。我不知道，这很棒。
This, of course, is Raquel. Raquel is beautiful, driven, and just quick. She's the friend you want sitting shotgun when you're lost driving.
这当然就是拉克尔。拉克尔漂亮、有冲劲，反应极快。如果你开车迷路了，她就是你想坐在副驾驶座上的那种人。
Raquel and Jonathan were both selected for the Fieldston program. And for Raquel, seeing Fieldston was a revelation. She remembers specific details-- the trees in the quad, that the library was a freestanding building. She remembers walking up to it.
拉克尔和乔纳森都被选入了菲尔德斯顿项目。对拉克尔来说，参观菲尔德斯顿是一种启示。她记得具体的细节——方院里的树，图书馆是一栋独立的建筑。她记得走过去的情景。
And we get in. And there were kids hanging out on the floor, and with their book bags, and kids leaving their book bags unattended. And like this is unheard of, I mean, I'm sorry. In the Bronx, you don't leave your book bag on the floor and walk away. You know what I mean? With a Mac laptop inside, you know what I mean? That just doesn't happen. And you don't get to sit on the floor at the school in a laid back kind of relaxed way.
我们进去的时候，有些孩子坐在地上，背着书包，而且孩子们的书包都无人看管。这在当时简直闻所未闻。在布朗克斯，你不可能把书包放在地上就走开，你知道我的意思吗？里面还有苹果笔记本电脑，你明白吗？那根本不会发生。而且在那个学校，你也不会被允许那样随性地坐在地上。
Raquel says she had the following thoughts all within the first few minutes. These kids are free. This is what freedom looks like. We must not deserve to be free. And finally, I am really lucky to be seeing this.
拉克尔说她在最初的几分钟内产生了以下念头：“这些孩子是自由的。这就是自由的样子。我们一定是不配拥有自由。最后，能看到这一切我真的很幸运。”
I mean, it's one thing hearing it from Pablo, but it's another thing seeing those things. You don't know how little you have because you don't have anything to compare it to. So I think it motivates you. For me, that's what the connection with the Fieldston school did for me-- it motivated me.
我的意思是，从巴勃罗那儿听是一回事，亲眼看到这些是另一回事。你不知道你拥有的多贫乏，因为你没有任何可比的东西。所以我认为这激励了你。对我来说，这就是和菲尔德斯顿学校的连接所带给我的——它激励了我。
As for me, I didn't feel like I was shit anyway, and I would never be shit. So I was just like, well, this is where the rich people are.
至于我，反正我觉得自己算个屁，我也永远成不了什么人物。所以我只是觉得：好吧，这就是富人待的地方。
Raquel says everyone felt bad seeing Fieldston, but Jonathan more so because he had been taught to feel that way at home.
拉克尔说每个人看到菲尔德斯顿都觉得难受，但乔纳森更是如此，因为他在家就被教导要那样想。
We had a lot of arguments about his mom, but he knows now. He saw himself through her eyes in a lot of ways. She made him feel very low at times. So I tried to love him and show him the support.
我们关于他的母亲吵过很多架，但他现在知道了。他在很多方面通过她（母亲）的眼睛来看待自己。她有时让他觉得自己很卑微。所以我试着去爱他，给他支持。
She says she just told him over and over how special he was.
她说她一次又一次地告诉他他有多特别。
Yeah, because he was. He was-- and he is. He's a remarkable man, and he's very talented. He deserved what this world had to offer him. And he had to take it.
是的，因为他确实是。他过去是，现在也是。他是个了不起的人，非常有才华。他理应得到这个世界所能提供给他的东西。而且他必须去争取。
That was how Jonathan went from imagining himself as a janitor to applying for college-- not because he saw Fieldston, because Raquel saw Fieldston. Raquel wanted to go to a college where she could sit on the rug and debate with friends, laptop on the floor by her knee.
这就是乔纳森从设想自己是个清洁工到申请大学的过程——不是因为他看到了菲尔德斯顿，而是因为拉克尔看到了菲尔德斯顿。拉克尔想去一所大学，在那里她可以坐在地毯上和朋友辩论，笔记本电脑放在膝盖边的地板上。
Senior year, they were both nominated for a Posse scholarship. Raquel didn't make it past the first round, but she went on to apply to lots of other schools and got into Bard College with a scholarship. And Jonathan got Posse. He got into Wheaton College in Massachusetts.
高三那年，他们都被提名参加Posse奖学金。拉克尔没闯过第一轮，但她继续申请了许多其他学校，并以奖学金被巴德学院（Bard College）录取。乔纳森则拿到了Posse奖学金，被马萨诸塞州的惠顿学院（Wheaton College）录取。
I think it was a Friday. I think it was a Friday they gave me-- that I had the letter in the mail from Wheaton. My main thing was, who am I to be accepted into a college?
我想那是个周五。我收到那封来自惠顿的信。我最主要的想法是：我算什么东西能被一所大学录取？
Wait. That was your first thought?
等等。那是你的第一个念头？
Yeah.
是的。
Did you have any moment of, this is great, I got into college?
你有过一刻觉得“这太棒了，我被录取了”吗？
No, I was scared.
没有，我很害怕。
You skipped right past excitement?
你直接跳过了兴奋阶段？
Yeah. There was no real excitement. I was just like, all right, so now what?
是的。没什么真正的兴奋。我只是想：好吧，那现在怎么办？
Did something change from November to whenever you arrived at college where you started to feel like, OK, I'm a person who goes to college?
从11月到你到校之间，有没有什么改变让你开始觉得“好吧，我是个上大学的人”？
I can't really say, yes, you know? Because at the core, I still didn't feel like I was worthy. And when I got to college, it showed.
我真的说不上来，你知道吗？因为在内心深处，我仍然觉得我不够格。当我到了大学，这显现出来了。
Jonathan's first day at Wheaton, he looked up his course syllabi and panicked. He couldn't afford the books. He also did not tell anyone he couldn't afford the books, he just never got them.
乔纳森第一天到惠顿，查了课程大纲，然后慌了。他买不起书。他也从没告诉任何人他买不起，只是从来没去买。
I didn't do the homework. So I'm going now into a class where, one, it's a different dynamic. Now I'm in Fieldston where it's 12 kids to a teacher. And I'm the only black kid in some of these classes. I'm the only kid in some of these classes.
我没做作业。所以走进教室时，一方面那是不同的动态环境。现在我到了菲尔德斯顿，12个孩子配一个老师。在某些课上，我是唯一的黑人。在某些课上，我是唯一的孩子。
So now I'm embarrassed to be the only black guy that doesn't do the work and fulfill that stereotype. So I'm not going to class. It's a catch-22 because now I'm still the black kid now that just doesn't come to class and doesn't do the work on top of that, you know? But for me, it was-- I mean, what am I going to say to these teachers?
所以现在我很尴尬，作为唯一的黑人男学生不交作业，从而坐实了那种刻板印象。所以我开始逃课。这很矛盾，因为现在我还是那个既不来上课也不做作业的黑人孩子，而且还加重了这种印象，你知道吗？但对我来说……我的意思是，我能对这些老师说什么？
In the beginning, I struggled too. My first year, I got C-pluses and B-minuses. It was devastating to me because I was an A-plus student in high school. And we both were like, this is a lot. This is crazy. I wasn't expecting this.
起初，我也挣扎过。大一我拿了C+和B-。这对我来说是毁灭性的，因为我在高中是全A学生。我们俩当时都觉得：这压力太大了。太疯狂了。我没预料到会这样。
And would you guys talk about that?
你们会聊这些吗？
Yeah, we talked about it.
会，我们聊过。
Was it nice to have somebody to--
有个人来……
It was nice to have somebody to talk about it with because my parents hadn't gone to college. Nobody could really help us, you know? We just sort of needed to figure it out together. We kind of troubleshooted some problems, like the book situation.
有个人能聊聊真好，因为我的父母没上过大学。没人能真正帮助我们，你知道吗？我们只能自己想办法解决。我们一起排除了一些难题，比如买书的情况。
Were you the one who told him that he should go to the library?
是你告诉他应该去图书馆的吗？
Mm-hm. Yeah, because that's what I was doing.
嗯，是的。因为我就是那么做的。
It had not occurred to either of them that the beautiful, freestanding library on campus was there to serve them and had a lot of the books they needed for free. But when Raquel panicked, she went to the student center and learned about the library and the interlibrary loan system. She told Jonathan, 200 miles away, who still had not asked a soul.
他们俩都没意识到校园里那座漂亮的独立图书馆是为了服务他们，而且里面有很多他们需要的书是免费的。但当拉克尔恐慌时，她去了学生活动中心，了解到了图书馆和馆际互借系统。她告诉了200英里外一直没敢开口询问的乔纳森。
And Jonathan was the one who was in Posse. Posse scholars have a 90% college graduation rate. The program is full of supports for kids just like him. He had months of training from Posse before he even went to college. He had a special campus mentor. Posse was calling him and sending him letters. He was ignoring it all. A few months into his first semester, Jonathan was barely getting outside of his room-- or his head.
而乔纳森还是Posse学者。Posse学者的大学毕业率是90%。这个项目充满了对像他这样孩子的支持。在去大学之前，他接受了几个月的Posse培训。他还有特别的校园导师。Posse不断给他打电话和寄信。他全部忽略了。第一学期几个月后，乔纳森几乎不出房间，也不出自己的内心世界。
I need to go to class. You need to talk to somebody. And then there's another voice that's like, nah, you're going to be embarrassed. It's embarrassing. Anyway, you're not going to have the money, so how is that going to help?
“我得去上课。你得去找人聊聊。”然后又有个声音说：“不，你会很尴尬的。这很丢人。反正你也付不起钱，这有什么用呢？”
You know, asking for help is being vulnerable. And the only person I was vulnerable with was Raquel. And sometimes, I would just lie like, yeah, I did homework today.
你知道，请求帮助意味着变得脆弱。而我唯一能脆弱面对的人就是拉克尔。有时，我会撒谎说：“是的，我今天做作业了。”
To her?
对她？
Yeah.
是的，因为压力太大了。但我……我只是不想向他们请求帮助。
You started lying to her?
因为我没在他身边，帮不上忙，也没法拯救他——我不是在试图拯救他，但……你知道，我试过一切办法让他保持浮在水面，尽管我自己也快淹没了。但我们是在一起漂浮。
Yeah, because it was too much pressure. But-- and I don't-- I just don't want help from them.
但他有时看起来快要沉下去了。我试图帮他。但后来……过了一段时间就不够了，你知道吗？他厌倦了我的推动。他有点……我不知道……就那样放弃了。
Because I wasn't in close proximity to him and I couldn't help, and I couldn't save him-- and I wasn't trying to save him, but it was like-- you know, I tried everything to sort of keep him afloat, even though I was barely with my head above the water as well. But we were floating together.
放弃了你？
But he seemed like, at times, he would drown. And I was trying to help him. But it got to be-- it wasn't enough after a certain amount of time, you know? He was tired of me pushing him. He sort of just-- you know, I don't know-- just kind of let go.
是的，是的。
Of you?
大三那年年中，拉克尔放弃了乔纳森。他们分手了。此时，乔纳森已经落后太多，学校警告他会被开除。他已经被停学两次了。
Yeah. Yeah.
他没有回复信件，没告诉任何人发生了什么。乔纳森似乎无法看清自己面临的境地有多糟糕。那年圣诞假期后，他回到了学校。
In the middle of her junior year, Raquel let go of Jonathan. They broke up. By this point, Jonathan was so far behind, the school was warning him he'd be expelled. He'd already been suspended twice.
我发现自己从惠顿退学的方式是回到学校。室友开了门，他说：“是啊，老兄，他们换了锁。有人要住进来了。”就在那一刻，我心想：噢，糟了。
He did not respond to the letters, did not tell anyone what was happening. Jonathan appeared to be unable to see how bad it was himself. He went back to school after Christmas break that year.
院长说：“你必须立即离开。你不能待在这个校园里。你必须马上走。”我觉得我得回家跟我妈妈说：“听着，你说得对。我真是个废物。”
The way I found out that I failed out of Wheaton was by going back to the school. And my roommate opened the door, and he was like, yeah, man, they changed the lock. Somebody else is coming in. And so right then, I was like, oh, shit.
乔纳森回到布朗克斯，在健身房的前台找了份工作，搬回了妈妈家。拉克尔完成了大四，没有乔纳森。她在Facebook上删了他的好友。
And the dean was like, you need to leave immediately. You cannot be on this campus. You need to leave immediately. I felt like I had to go to my mom and say, listen, you were right. I'm not shit.
但她Facebook上的其他朋友似乎也在挣扎着同样的问题。拉克尔总能看到同样的消息：某某从那所学校退学了，或者哪个孩子太爱聚会结果被开除了。她的高中朋友一个接一个在大学失败。乔纳森不是个例，她是那个例外。到她毕业时，拉克尔是她所知的唯一一个坚持下来的人。
Jonathan came back to the Bronx, got a job at the front desk of a gym, and moved back in with his mom. Raquel finished her senior year without Jonathan. She unfriended him on Facebook.
拉克尔进入中产阶级的可能性比乔纳森高出一倍以上——统计上来看，她更有可能获得就业、保持健康、享受日常工作、拥有美满婚姻。但大多数进入大学的贫困孩子都没能毕业。事实上，这个数字低得令人震惊。不到五分之一的人能在六年内完成学业。
But other friends she had on Facebook seemed to be struggling with the same things he had. All the time, Raquel would see the same news. So-and-so flunked out of that school, or this kid partied too much and got kicked out. Her high school friends were failing at college, one by one. Jonathan was not the anomaly, she was. By the time she graduated, Raquel was the only person she knew of who made it.
现在有成群的研究人员正试图弄清该怎么做。教育是跨越阶级壁垒的最佳途径，但在许多情况下，教育本身似乎也成了障碍。巴勃罗·穆里尔，那个所有这些孩子都记得且爱戴的高中老师，对此深有体会。听听当我问巴勃罗是否还记得拉克尔时发生了什么。
Raquel is now more than twice as likely as Jonathan to make it into the middle class-- statistically more likely to be employed, to be healthy, to enjoy her daily work, to have a happy marriage. But most poor kids who make it to college do not make it to graduation. In fact, the number is shockingly low. Less than one fifth finish in six years.
是的，拉克尔。我当然记得她。她去了巴德学院。
There are swarms of researchers trying to figure out what to do about this right now. Education is the best way to cross class barriers. And in many cases, education seems to be the barrier. Pablo Muriel, the high school teacher who all these kids remember and loved, he knows this very well. Just listen to what happened when I asked Pablo if he remembered Raquel.
是的，她去了。她现在是一名老师。
Yeah, Raquel. Of course, I remember her. She went to Bard-- Bard College.
她已经毕业了？
Yeah, she did. She's a teacher now.
她毕业了，正在教书。
She's already graduated?
（倒吸一口气）我为她感到骄傲。太美妙了。噢，天哪。我为她感到自豪。太棒了。
She graduated and she's teaching.
巴勃罗是波多黎各人，在布朗克斯的政府公屋长大。所以当他告诉孩子们他们能上大学时，那是可信的，因为他做到了。他大学毕业，去了研究生院，周游世界。
(GASPING) I'm so proud of her. That's beautiful. Oh, my god. I'm so proud of her. That's beautiful. That's awesome.
巴勃罗说看到像他们一样的人成功对孩子很重要。但他对自己扮演这个角色感到深深的矛盾。他依然告诉孩子们要去上大学，因为除此之外他还能做什么？
Pablo is Puerto Rican. He grew up in the Bronx, in the projects. So when he told kids they could make it to college, it was credible because he did it. He graduated college. He went to graduate school, traveled the world.
那是一种值得追求的东西。我不想让他们觉得这就到头了，没有出路。但不幸的是……我要说得非常诚恳……对于我毕业后保持联系的绝大多数孩子——只有少数几个人真正成为了“拉克尔”。
Pablo says it's important for kids to see someone like them succeed. But he also feels deeply ambivalent about playing this role. He still tells kids to go to college because what else is he supposed to do?
昨天还有个孩子来看我，安东尼，他去了汉普郡学院，拿了全额奖学金。他一年后给我打电话说：“我做不到，对不起，我要离开了。”哥伦比亚大学、福特汉姆大学……
And it's sort of something to reach for. I didn't want them to feel like this is it, and there's no way out. But unfortunately-- I'm going to be very sincere-- with most of the kids that have graduated-- I've kept in touch with so many of them-- only a handful have actually been the Raquel Hardys.
还有一位参加过那个项目的年轻女士。她去了福特汉姆大学，也退学了。她承受不了。我们说的是布朗克斯，你知道吗？福特汉姆大学，她都搞不定。
I just had someone visit me yesterday, Anthony, who went to Hampshire, got a full scholarship. He called me a year later and said, I can't do it. I'm sorry. I'm leaving, you know? Columbia University, Fordham University.
巴勃罗说巴德学院、哥伦比亚大学，这些都是“菲尔德斯顿”。他推测他许多以前的学生所经历的，很可能和他们在菲尔德斯顿经历的一样。他们被扔进了一片异域，并被要求在精神上想象自己属于那里。
There was one young lady who was part of that program, as well. She went to Fordham University, and she left. She couldn't hack it. And we're talking about the Bronx, you know? Fordham University. She couldn't do it.
这很难做到。事实上，拉克尔人生的全部计划就是试图说服自己她是属于那里的。在这方面，她是一个心理上的斗士。因为这个项目并没有在她进入名校时结束。它并没有在她从那所大学毕业时结束，也没有在她大学毕业后，获得一家律师事务所的律师助理面试机会时结束。
Pablo says Bard College, Columbia, these are Fieldstons. And he imagines that what happened to lots of his former students is probably the same thing that happened to them at Fieldston. They were dropped into a foreign land and asked to mentally imagine themselves as belonging.
尽管我通过优秀的简历和不错的电话面试获得了机会，但当我进入那里时，我心想：我不配拥有这些。这……薪水等级比我理应得到的要高。这比我父母两人赚的钱都要多。
That's hard to do. In fact, the entire project of Raquel's life has been trying to convince herself she does belong. In this regard, she is a mental gladiator. Because this project did not end when she got into the prestigious college. It did not end when she graduated from that college or when, after college, she landed an excellent job interview at a law firm to be a paralegal.
每当我走进试图申请工作的地方，这些念头就会在脑海中闪过。既然连你自己都不相信，你怎么能让别人相信你配得上这份工作呢？这就像我生命中反复出现的主题。我必须告诉自己我配得上这一切，因为我工作非常努力。
Even though I got my foot in the door by having a good resume and maybe giving a good phone interview, when I get in there, I'm like, I don't deserve this. It's not-- the pay grade salary was above what I deserve. This is more money than either of my parents have ever made, probably.
她必须忽略她高中时没能享受到那座豪华图书馆，忽略她在大学拿到的糟糕成绩，忽略她付不起书费的事实，忽略她是班里唯一黑人孩子的事实，忽略她的大学同学早在高中就知道如何正确使用分号的事实，忽略Facebook流里那些高中朋友一个个退学的消息，以及那个比她更深刻地相信——被所有这些证据反复证实——他不配得到这一切的男友。拉克尔必须不去看那堆证明她努力可能徒劳的证据，取而代之的是不断对自己重复：你配得上这一切。你配得上这一切。你配得上这一切。
And those things go through my mind when I'm walking into a place that I'm trying to apply for work. And so how could you convince somebody that you deserve it when you don't even believe it yourself? It's like a reoccurring theme in my life. I have to tell myself that I deserve this because I work really hard for it.
这就是我在菲尔德斯顿时所做的。这也是我在巴德时所做的，也是我在面试时所做的。这就是我在工作中做的事。
She has to ignore the fancy library that she did not get to enjoy in high school, the bad grades she got in college, the fact that she can't afford books, the fact that she's the only black kid in class, the fact that her peers in college already knew how to use a semicolon correctly, the Facebook stream of high school friends dropping out of college one at a time, and the boyfriend who deeply, more deeply than her, believes the message confirmed again and again by all these things, that he is unworthy. Raquel has to not look at the mountain of evidence that what she's working toward will not be possible, and instead has to repeat to herself, you do deserve this. You deserve this. You do deserve this.
拉克尔一直等待着那种优越感的到来，那种她在巴德学院的同伴身上看到的虚张声势。她可以装出来，但她还没达到真正发自内心感受到它的地步。我向巴勃罗提到了这一点。
And that's what I did while I was at Fieldston. And that's what I did when I was at Bard. And that's what I do on my job interviews now. That's what I do at work.
我非常真诚地告诉你：我今年36岁，我有两个硕士学位，现在正处于准备论文阶段——我正在写博士论文——但我依然有那种感觉。这种感觉永远不会消失。
Raquel keeps waiting for the sense of entitlement to set in, the bravado she sees in her peers from Bard. She can fake it, but she hasn't gotten to the point where she truly feels it. I mentioned this to Pablo.
这群孩子在十年前第一次窥见了围栏外面的世界。而那个15岁时因为太过压抑而跑掉的女孩梅兰妮，现在已经25岁了。她还是15岁时的那个人，但身边再也没有人告诉她：“你出类拔萃，你会有一番作为。”有的只是高端超市里的顾客，门外挂着红色条幅，宣布楼上就是豪华公寓。
And I'm going to be very sincere with you. I am 36 years old, and I have two master's degrees, and I'm all but dissertation at this point-- I'm working on my dissertation now-- and I still feel that way. It is something that will never leave.
当你描述在菲尔德斯顿看到那些孩子会成为医生、律师，而我们将成为为他们开门、服务他们的人时，你觉得那现在就是你吗？
This group of kids got their first peek over the fence a decade ago now. And Melanie, the girl who found it so upsetting as a 15-year-old that she ran away, she's 25 now. She's the same person she was at 15, but there are no longer people around to tell her, you are exceptional. You're going to make something of yourself. What there is are customers in an upscale supermarket with red banners out front announcing luxury apartments upstairs.
绝对是。100%。这就是为什么我对自己的工作感到如此羞愧。我不怎么告诉别人我靠什么为生。你知道，我觉得我们待在那儿就是为了服务那样的人。而我服务的对象就是这些人，他们绝对会表达出他们比我们优越，让你知道你不在他们的层次上。
When you described being at Fieldston and seeing these kids are going to be doctors and lawyers and we're going to be the people opening doors for them and serving them, do you feel like that's you now?
我讨厌告诉别人我在哪工作，因为我讨厌……那是家超市。而那是……我真的很想摆脱它。那已经是我生命中快九年的时间了，我心想：我必须向前看。我真的只想走出来。
Absolutely. 100%. That's why I'm so ashamed of my job. I don't really tell people what I do for a living. You know, I felt like we were there to service people like that. And that's what I service. I service people that definitely express that they're better than us and let you know you're not on their level.
在和所有人聊过之后，我脑海中总有一件事在重演。那是安吉拉·瓦索斯告诉我的关于梅兰妮被明德学院录取的故事。还记得吗？菲尔德斯顿那个私立学校的老师？记得安吉拉的记忆有多生动吗？
I hate telling people where I work, because I hate-- it's a supermarket. And that's-- I really want to shake that off of me. That's been almost nine years of my life, and I'm just like, I have to move on. I just really want out.
“她说：梅兰妮，过来。梅兰妮走过去。房间里有50人。她说：明德学院录取你了，全额奖学金。”
There's this one thing I keep replaying in my head after talking to all these people. It's the story Angela Vassos told me about Melanie getting into Middlebury. Do you remember that? The teacher from Fieldston, the private school? You remember how vivid Angela's memory was?
梅兰妮没进明德学院。她根本不记得这一刻。但安吉拉记得，记得很清楚。即使在今天，她承认那一定不是真实发生的事，但她就是记得。
And she says, Melanie, come here. Melanie goes up. There are 50 people in the room. She says, Middlebury accepted you, full scholarship.
我有个理论。我认为安吉拉之所以记得梅兰妮“成功了”——凯旋般地成功——是因为要相信梅兰妮没有成功真的很困难。我完全能理解这一点。
Melanie did not get into Middlebury. She doesn't remember this moment at all. But Angela does, clearly. Even today, she acknowledges it must not have been what really happened, but she remembers it.
我去年11月见了梅兰妮，现在依然每周给她打电话，只是问问：“所以最近怎么样——你的牙医、你的成绩、你和教授的会面？”我一直期待着会有消息，比如她要迎来转机或者什么事情会发生在好的一面。这感觉充满悬念，但10年来她身上什么也没发生。
I have a theory about this. I think Angela has this memory of Melanie making it-- triumphantly making it-- because it is really hard to believe that Melanie would not make it. And I can completely understand that.
我认为这是一种特殊的美国式病态乐观主义，我们中许多人都相信梅兰妮的故事结局一定是幸福的。如果不是，那一定发生了什么异常情况——而不是这只是常态，超市里可能挤满了像梅兰妮这样的人。
I met Melanie in November, and I still call her most weeks just to say, so what happened-- with your dentist, with your grades, with that meeting with your professor? I keep expecting there to be news, like she's about to get her big break or something and things will happen for her. It feels suspenseful, but nothing has happened for her for 10 years.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是我们节目的制作人之一。距离我们第一次播出这个故事已经过去三年了。拉克尔、乔纳森和梅兰妮都决定想成为像巴勃罗·穆里尔那样的教育工作者。拉克尔当老师已经有一段时间了；乔纳森最近成了布朗克斯的一名校内助理；梅兰妮还在超市工作，正努力争取一份校内助理的工作。
I think it's some special brand of American pathological optimism that so many of us believe the story of Melanie has to turn out to be happy. And that if it doesn't, something unusual has happened-- and not just this is what happens all the time, that the supermarket might be full of Melanies.
今天的节目由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）制作，佐伊·切斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、三木·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）以及阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）共同参与。高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。节目编辑由保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）和乔尔·洛弗尔（Joel Lovell）担任。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our program. It's now been three years since we first broadcast this story. Raquel, Jonathan, and Melanie all decided that they want to be educators like their teacher Pablo Muriel. And Raquel's been a teacher for awhile. Jonathan's recently become a school aide in the Bronx. Melanie is still at the supermarket, working toward a job as a school aid.
西蒙·阿德勒（Simon Adler）提供了制作协助。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是生产经理。伊莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是办公室经理。阿德里安·马西奥韦茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）负责网站运营。艾尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）为我们的节目搜寻故事素材。感谢米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）提供的研究协助。感谢罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）在音乐上的帮助。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Editing on today's show from Paul Tough and Joel Lovell.
（致谢）
Production help from Simon Adler. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help today from Michelle Harris. Music help from Rob Geddis.
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，每年碧昂丝没能赢得年度专辑时，托里走出我们的格莱美派对时都会说：
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
“这不公平，这……我不想待在这里。我要走。我离开这儿了。我现在就回家。”
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, every year when Beyonce fails to win album of the year, Torey walks out of our Grammy party saying--
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给大家更多《美国生活》的故事。
This is unfair. This is-- I don't want to be here. I'm leaving. I'm leaving right now. I'm going home.
这不公平。这——我不想待在这里。我要走了。我现在就要走。我要回家。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，继续为您带来《美国生活》的更多故事。